pat est venu délivrer des chars d'amis
ont parfois fait tous les jours
si le pays joyeux des enfants heureux
des monstres gentils wii s'est très bien
passée c'était merveilleux
nous avons été pique nique et de l'autre
côté de l'île il y avait un soleil
splendide il nous avons vu 40 est une
espèce de papillon points moi j'en ai vu
quatre à quatre c'est formidable
si nous avons fait plein de jeux et moi
j'ai presque gagnée aux devinettes
mais tu as perdu j'ai perdu simplement
parce que je n'avais pas trouvé les
bonnes réponses
enfin ne coûtent que j'ai eues mais si
je n'a pas trouvé les bonnes réponses
il est tout à fait normal que tu es
perdu ça nous intéresse personne gelé le
pique nique était beau fameux oui moi ma
glace aux anchois manqué un petit peu de
cas à écoute qu'elle est maire il n'y a
pas que toi sur terre cesse de parler
toujours uniquement de toi mais enfin si
je ne parle pas de moi qui va en parler
or on ne fera même pas que j'existe à
entremont petit dur ça nous parlons très
souvent toi tous nos amis te connaissent
c'est vrai vous dit du bien de moi
bien sûr si tu le mérites mais il faut
aussi que nous puissions parler des
autres sur ça ce serait injuste mais je
ne peux paraître injuste avec les autres
mais je ne veux pas non plus que l'on
soit injuste avec moi ces coûts bon je
vous laisse je vais jouer l'un peu plus
loin dont casimir je suis fier de toi
pour te récompense et je te permet de
choisir le bon que tu voudras le bon
bout que je voudrais oui même si c'est à
caramel au poivre
si ça te fait plaisir mais attention tu
ne trouveras pas dans le bocal de
bonbons qui se trouve sur le rayon des
farces et attrapes et caramel on poindre
avec les farces et attrapes
quelle drôle d'idée merci quand même
suivi
bon voilà partait il est vraiment
sympathique et bien sûr mais tout le
monde n est il croit toujours qu'on ne
pense pas les que veux-tu c'est son
caractère faut essayer de le comprendre
et toi alors comment ta journée c'est
pas le passé une façon formidable j'ai
lu presque entièrement le tour du monde
en 80 jours du livre à des supers oui ce
phileas fogg ça c'est un homme
extraordinaire
tu te rends compte qu'il a fait le tour
du monde en 80 jours
juste pour un pari avec les camarades de
club sans compter qu'à cette époque vous
ne connaissez pas les avions
supersoniques ni même les avis en tout
court tu crois qu'il a vraiment du tout
mais non c'est jules verne qui l'a
imaginé mais tous à cette époque il a
quand même exister de grands voyageurs
qui ont fait preuve d'autant de courage
que phileas fogg laventure ce doit être
formidable
moi j'aimerais bien connaître des gens
comme ceux phileas fogg il faudra qu'une
telle personne passe à jour par l'île
aux enfants parce que je ne vois pas ici
quelqu'un de capable de faire un tel
exploit
enfin on s'amuse bien quand même et bien
sûr et puis nous avons tellement d'amis
tu viens m'aider à vider mon panier
certainement tu veux quoi en premier les
assiettes les assiettes vienne et voilà
les verts voilà les faits découverts
oui il reste également sas également 2e
dur
ah oui tu sais j'avais pris beaucoup
trop de provisions casimir c'est la
casquette de phileas fogg bois et alors
c'est pourquoi tu sais de casquette sur
la tête mais vous ne savez pas la grande
nouvelle
quelle nouvelle tout quoi s'agit-il eh
bien je vais partir pour faire le tour
du monde
en face en 19 jours pour battre sauf si
les masses frog fait tu veux sans doute
parler de phileas fogg
oui enfin mes mails à ce fils de
philippe maes rogge peu importe le nom
ce qui est important c'est de faire le
tour du monde en moins de 80 jours et
comment vas-tu partir d'un avion alors
casimir ton exploit n'existera plus
n'importe quelle personne qui aurait de
quoi se payer un billet d'avion est
capable de faire le tour du monde
bien moins que 79 jours tu es sapin
certains forme alors qu'est ce que je
vais faire et bien du a droit à tous les
autres moyens de locomotion
qu'est-ce que ça ait les moyens de
locomotion ce sont les engins qui te
permet de déplacer les voitures les
bateaux les motos mais moi je ne connais
pas grand chose à ces changements du
sein eh bien tu vas jusqu'à la
bibliothèque de l'île pour te documenter
français une idée merci françois j 20 8
en attendant je lui prépare moi en
vitesse à un petit sandwich pour mon
voyage
il trouvera de simples justin volutes du
jambon avec du gruyère de la moutarde et
des conditions la confiture de fraise et
la compote de pommes c'est tout nosy
dual tentures à jour des anchois et et
des tomates
je vais chercher ma documentation à tout
à l'heure
voilà bon bah ça y est tout est prêt
j'ai donc une moto une locomotive un
avion une voiture et un bateau bien pour
moi je crois que je sais vraiment tout
sur les moyens de locomotion et jeu cela
enfin prêt à partir pour le tour du
monde en 79 jours françois j'ai bien
peur au contraire que tu es tout
mélanger tu crois si nous demandions aux
enfants de nous aider ah oui oui ça
c'est une très bonne idée
et vous si cheyrou vous aiderez casimir
le stage les enfants mes amis vous ne
verrez là venez casimir a besoin de vous
pour mes moyens de locomotion regardez
c'est les yeux
est ce que quelque chose nous sommes la
normale oui quitte qui me donne un
exemple thierry la voix par exemple
qu'est-ce qui se tint ne va pas avec
l'automobile
mais alors qu'est ce qu'on met sur une
automobile comment elles marchent alors
par la loi comme casimir je crois que le
mieux c'est de tout défaire et de tout
replacer ensuite vous êtes d'accord les
enfants
leurs dimensions commençons par la moto
les roues ne vont pas et où pourrait
être pour les placer sur les ailes ne
vont pas sur l autre et je mets lire ou
a dans ce sens là bon voilà oui
peut-être police je retire les rênes sur
la locomotive
alors les ailes on l'aimé ou et j'arrive
sur l'avion de l'avion est normale ce
qui ne va pas qui est il anormal ni
cédés ou alors je mets le bateau mais on
est devant un gouvernail non attendez
alors maintenant on avait le gouvernail
anton boerner jeunes est ici c'est un
gouvernail de bateau sur le batteur
voilà c'est de rouler en moto
haas a l'air d'aller mal est fait bon
bah ça y est tout est parfait l'amour
estimant qu' on en est loin casimir ah
bon la moto ça va redescendre
les lignes et les passes sur terre
l'échalas sur l'écran bon voila voila je
la voulais aussi que la locomotive à la
redescente ont aussi jacques sur le
bateau ne voudront aller violent on ne
retire le volant du bateau en mer où il
ya un gouvernail ça suffit mais le
marbre et les voiles ne faut qu'elle
aggravera bon sayah sayan venant ici le
volant je ne mets sur la voiture pour
les routes voilà rôles de tonnes et bien
voilà casimir pourquoi on tire tu ta
casquette de phileas fogg
on va encore plus faire le tour du monde
en 72 jours
non franchement j'ai réfléchi je crois
qu'il vaut beaucoup mieux que je fasse
simplement le tour de l'île aux enfants
en 79 minutes
[Musique]